all right let's go lower it down yep
let's cut it yeah oh i'm getting the
hang of this now
i say that but it's still not easy to
handle this beast and a bus frame is
gonna be a lot more to chop than this
trailer house frame
pull back with the right stick
first piece we can use yeah i got it
there you go like that good job oh whoa
yeah we got it
we got to cut there there's another
piece all right bobby one more cut and
you're done here we go baby
good cut we can shut her down
is he doing all right took a little
while but he got there
all right bobby come on let's go i just
got the hang of this one
scrapping the bust is a three-step
process i figured out the loader pretty
quick
but i struggled with the shear only one
more thing to learn
how to use a grapple another big
villain-like looking machine
oh okay all right we'll throttle it up
throttle is up same thing up down yeah
open close
this is like the claw game at showbiz
pizza when i was a kid
let's go down the key is getting those
claws through the windows
so i can get a good hold okay i gotta
hold that you're ready to pick the car
up
okay oh baby
oh my god now you're ready to swing
around
[Music]
are you kidding me golly
man i had a good grip but i didn't
realize it would slip out if i eased up
on the controls
if i squeeze tight to the lever the
grapple will keep hold of the car
oh boy now you're ready to swing to the
boat keep your grapples squeezed tight
as you go
okay we are moving doors should be open
on the baler and
set it in there oh god all right go
ahead and come down a little with
it that's a low it should be a safe
distance all right let's go
drop and sesame
yeah close the big door the baler
crushes the cars down
into giant scrap metal bricks which
makes it easier to load onto flatbed
trucks
to be shipped out to the recycling
facility
now your top left button here it is the
grand reveal
why are you ready to get your car out of
there let's go down
okay i'm on squeeze
looks like a bell from here that's a
damn good bale
spin back around the way you got it got
it and don't drop it
i'm holding it where do i put it oh god
we're gonna set it down gently on the
back of that truck
by the way bobby this is my mechanic
freedom your name's fredo
that's the coolest name i heard a long
time man that's awesome i'm bobby good
to meet you
nice to meet you bobby we're gonna set
that bail gently down on this truck
that's not my truck bobby
we can't tear it up don't you have your
own flatbed if you drop that bell on
this one i may have to buy it
so ease it down on there all right baby
slow and steady wins the race
keep going keep going so much pressure
keep going
that's good turn it loose yeah i'm
[Music]
surprised
[Music]
you